this week two issues have highlighted
significant divisions within the labor
party transgender law reform and NHS
reform so no surprise that kirstama
avoided both today instead returning to
the safer topic of long waits for
ambulances and the labor leaders started
with a test for the PM about timing
Mr Speaker it's three minutes past 12.
if somebody phones if somebody phones
999 now because they have chest pains
and fear it might be a heart attack
when would the Prime Minister expect an
ambulance to arrive if our heart attack
victim had called for an ambulance in
Peterborough at 1203 it wouldn't arrive
until 10 past two if they were in
Plymouth it wouldn't arrive until twenty
to three
the Prime Minister responded with his
usual lines Labor's too close to the
unions is playing politics and won't
back the government's new minimum
service law Richardson also attacked the
party's record in the one government it
currently runs
Mr Speaker I noticed that one place The
Honorable gentleman didn't mention was
Wales
where we know ambulance times are
when they are in England
no and the reason the reason that is the
case because this is not about politics
this is about the fact that the NHS in
Scotland in Wales in England
dealing with unprecedented challenges
recovering from covid dealing with a
very virulent and early flu season and
everyone is doing their best to bring
those wait times down from then on
conservative MPS shouted Wales at
kierstama just listen
by one o'clock our heart attack victim
is in a bad way sweaty dizzy chest
tightening
this is a heart attack and they're
shouting this is your constituent the
labor benches were equally Rowdy while
repeat offender Rachel Reeves kept
uncharacteristically quiet her Shadow
cabinet colleagues Unleashed A Chorus of
disapproval but Rishi sunak cheered his
side with this finale
when it comes to the honorable gentleman
he isn't just for the free movement of
people he's also got the free movement
of principles
very good very good said the Home
Secretary
Moore shouted Tory MPS and then this
the other big political story this week
the UK government's controversial move
to block Scotland's new gender
recognition law and its implications for
devolution
Mr Speaker let me be crystal clear this
is the conservative party seeking to
stalk a culture war against some of the
most marginalized people in society and
Scotland's democracy is simply
collateral damage are we not now on a
slippery slope from devolution to direct
rule
yes no Mr Speaker of course we're not
this is simply about protecting uk-wide
legislation about ensuring the safety of
women and children this is not about the
Devolution settlement well the SMP is
highly likely to return to that
sensitive and pre-divisive issue in the
coming weeks and if strikes and delays
in the NHS continue labor may also
resurrect their questions so get
comfortable because it looks like a
political war of attrition has begun